my name is Lynn Cooley and I'm very glad
to have you here at our very first
company of scholars lecture for the
2014-15 academic year this is the 16th
year of our Dean's lecture series in the
Graduate School and it is designed to
bring students faculty staff and
community members together across the
disciplines to hear from our own
distinguished Yale alumni we get few
chances to do that I'm thrilled to carry
on this grad school tradition as the new
dean of the Graduate School
in addition today we have something very
special and a little unusual planned
instead of a lecture by a single faculty
member we have a team here Valerie
Hanson Gary Miller and Anders Wynn Roth
all historians on the on the world circa
1000 the lecture is based on their
collaborative venture which is a
graduate course of the same name taught
this semester that leads students on a
remarkable tour of the world during the
Year 1000 when various regions of the
globe took part in complex social
economic and cultural networks across
continents valerie hansen is a professor
of history she started at yale in 1993
her work focuses on medieval China
Chinese religious and legal history and
the history of the Silk Road her 2012
book the Silk Road a new history was
described as the most readable and
reliable historical account of the
fabled trade route that cut across the
center of Eurasia in medieval times Mary
Miller the sterling professor of history
of art specializes in the art of the
ancient new world her work on ancient
Mexico and the Maya garnered national
recognition including a Guggenheim
Fellowship she's elected to the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences in 1994 and
this academic year she'll be delivering
sleighed lectures at Cambridge onder's
Wynne Roth is the forst family professor
of history his work explores the history
of medieval Europe particularly the
really
just intellectual and legal history
including the Viking Age
in 2003 onder's was named a MacArthur
Fellow for his work on the development
of medieval canon law as an important
antecedent to contemporary legal
reasoning thank you all for coming to
give us a glimpse of your combined
efforts in this class following the
lecture there will be plenty of time for
questions and then following questions
please join us in the common room which
is just adjacent for a reception so with
that I'll turn the podium over to our
speakers thank you all for coming the
plan for our 40-minute talk is a
30-month 39 minute plan each of us is
going to speak for ten minutes and then
this in the same order so we're starting
in Asia so it starts with me then we'll
go to Europe and Anders will take over
and then we will go to the Americas and
Mary will take over and then after we
have each spoken for ten minutes we will
return in that order and each speak for
three minutes the I was gonna say we
start I'd like to start with and just
say it's been such a pleasure to teach
with my colleagues there have been
extremely fun and a lot of information
has been on the table all the time the
in teaching the course I realized that
well we focus on the year 1000 because
so many of us think of the Age of
Exploration as starting at a later date
but in fact in the year 1000 there are a
lot of new connections among different
regions and that's what we'll be talking
about in this talk Thea and looking at
the map one of the first things we did
was ask the students to draw a map of
the world and and and this is a you know
given projections an accurate map of the
world but one of the things that really
interests me is the formation of
different regions and how we define
these regions and which regions are
closer or farther apart from each other
not necessarily just in terms of
distance but also in terms of ocean
currents but I'm going to start today
I'm talking about so
my remit is Asia and in the year 1000
very simply a line is formed here
between China and then a northern
dynasty called the liao that governs a
lot this is a grasslands across
Northeast Asia and this is a detailed
more detailed map of the liao they are
the liao dynasty and the coton people
and this purple area is the heart of the
empire where their Imperial tombs are
the this is one of the rare pictures we
have of the liao that doesn't barbarian
eyes them and maybe it's a copy a later
copy of a painting by a Keaton painter
and the Keaton and the song the Leo and
the Sung had a series of battles in
throughout the 10th century and then in
a thousand and four the Keaton won a
resounding victory over the sung and
they drew up a treaty between the two
powers the Chinese and the Keaton called
the Treaty of chan yuen-han in according
to which the Chinese agreed to pay a
hundred thousand taels of silver so
that's a tale of silver that's actually
50 taels of silver
it's au at 50 ounces of silver and then
two hundred thousand bolts of silk the
euphemism in the treaty was to help with
military expenses but this was because
the son had lost and that treaty really
draws a line between the Chinese and the
Keaton territory there's and there are
agreements about there are markets set
up on the border and certain goods are
not supposed to be traded some recent
work shows that the border is permeable
it's not as fixed as we once thought but
in fact the Keaton are oriented north
and west and the song beyond wort
reorient to the South East Asia and
import a lot of goods actually a lot of
strange fragrances like ambergris um
things we know from the Bible and myrrh
and frankincense so and the diplomacy at
this time some of the people who are
moving the farthest between among
different regions are envoys and we have
a written record on the Chinese side of
about the movement of envoys among
different places and the Keaton's make
an effort to sign is to form a ratio of
sorry to establish a relationship with
Islamic dynasty to the West in what's
now Afghanistan the Keaton have their
own written language we can barely read
it
so almost everything we know we know
from Chinese sources or from
archaeological sources and this is an
imperial tomb of a princess who died in
1018 it's the only Kiton tomb that was
not disturbed and you can see some of
the goods that the luxury goods that
were valued by the Keaton which in the
course we call bling and the and I've
got an arrow on the amber the amber is
very important so the good some of the
goods from this tomb date of 1018 than
Keaton territory in that purple area I
showed you at the beginning we've got
glass this is all of these things are
from the Islamic world so a glass bottle
probably from Egypt or Syria a rock
crystal bowl that is very small a plate
a metal plate with motifs on it that we
can match other plates that have been
found in Neesha por Iran and the Misha
port was under the rule of the Gus new
vids
that's this dynasty that was in
Afghanistan and into some of Iran and
the ghaznavids the Leo decide that the
Keaton's were up here decide to try to
form a diplomatic relationship with the
ghaznavids they send an envoy and we
know about this because an Islamic
geographer named marvadi tells us about
this and he tells us that the Envoy the
gifts that the Envoy presented to the
ghaznavids so silk clothing sable furs
the way our
had a lot of access to furs of North
Asia musk and then a bow with ten arrows
which was a symbolic gift of
establishing an allied relationship and
the ghaznavids replies and says this
that there's no faith uniting us
basically you are not Muslim and we are
and because you're so far away from us
we're safe they're protected distance
protects us from perfidy I have no need
of close relations with you until you
accept Islam and that is all
so the I was gonna say so oh oh it's
funny on my on Mary's computer this
slide is blank this is a map of the
Islamic world and this is so in my part
of the talk I want to establish three
regions or sketch three regions the
layout territory the song territory and
then the very large Islamic world in the
center and this is a map from a cup it's
a copy of a map of an Islamic map from
the 11 50s and it shows you the extent
of the world known to Islamic
geographers and they knew more about the
world than anybody else at this time in
the year 1000 the and one that same
Islamic geographer Marv Ozzie who told
us about the and the diplomatic attempt
for by the Liao to establish relations
with the governments also reports that
the main goods going from the Islamic
world to the Chinese and presumably the
Liao
were ivory frankincense and genuine
Slavonic amber and then who - who - is a
word that this is my transition to
unders this Slavonic amber amber has
actually been tested chemically that
this is nothing well some of the amber
from Liao tombs and it turns out it is
actually from the Baltic and then the
who - is walrus tusk and that is one of
the things linking East Asia and North
Asia with the parts with Europe and with
that under your on
thank you so the our princesses got
amber from the Baltic Sea the rulers of
Northern Europe also got things from
China and from the Far East this silk
cuff found in a Swedish Viking Age grave
does not come from silk made in China
but receipt mail it made in the Middle
East but there are other less photogenic
silk elsewhere in the graves that at
least European textile historians think
was woven in China
well the Valerie tells me that Chinese
textile historians do not agree how did
this get to all the way to northern
Europe let me tell you another story
this is about a not very ordinary school
class that was camping out in 1975 on
the island the swedish island of Gotland
in the Baltic Sea I'm sorry I wasn't
there I wasn't old enough by that time
they had been studying Viking history
for several months and as a grand
finale' they were doing this real
experience living like Vikings out in
nature they picked a good place a place
with mysterious ancient monuments a
place that according to local lore was
where the Viking chieftains star bar had
once hid his huge very valuable treasure
they had a very enjoyable time the last
morning they performed sacrifices in
front of an old bouta stone they
sacrificed smart smoked perch flowers
that they had picked pottery that they
had made and prayed that the gods in
return would give them money they needed
money and they wanted to go to Denmark
the bus that was going to pick them up
was late they packed everything up they
cleaned up they were waiting that
nothing to do as a beautiful Swedish
high summer's day they rested they were
relaxed they saw a rabbit scurrying
around on the meadow and they thought
let's catch it so they ran after it but
this was not a stupid rabbit this was a
Swedish rabbit sweet of course ran down
into his burrow
one of the most intrepid boys in the
class put his arm down the barrel would
it be bitten by the rabbit or would he
pull the wrap it out by its ears well
when he pulled the arm out he pulled out
something considerably more interesting
a coin an old coin with an inscription
that nobody could read they called the
local museum which immediately sent
archaeologists that excavated the
rabbits burrow and found 1452 silver
corns that have been put there at the
middle of the 10th century little before
the Year thousand most of them were Arab
silver coin from the Caliphate at the
other end of Europe how did they get
there to begin to answer that question I
want to tell you a third story bulgur at
the very least of Europe on the Volga
was a was a great market town in the
early 10th century it was the capital of
the bull gars who had recently arrived
they were ruled by ruler called
al mish even silky Gill tomorrow he had
decided that they needed to become
Muslim so he had let the Caliph in
Baghdad know about that the Caliph
santim diplomatic mission to bulgor to
convert them we know about this because
one of the participants of the mission a
man called Ahmed in fat LAN wrote a
report about
which has been preserved in an Iranian
library in fat LOM tells us that the
trip there took almost a year from
Baghdad to Bulgari
but he also tells us a lot about what he
saw in Bolger he was another alert
observer very curious about two strange
habits of this far far away people he
tells us a particular about it but about
a group of merchants who were riding
boats on the Volga Roos merchants
historians fight about who the roots
were but most agree nowadays that they
at least were partially made up of
Scandinavians he tells us about the ruse
that when they arrived from their
territory to Bulgari
they disembarked and the first thing
they do is to go out to a great pole set
in the ground that at the top of it as a
face like the face of a man in front of
the pole they prostrate themselves and
pray to their gods they say in furlan
tells us my lord I had come from a
faraway country and I'm bringing to you
I'm bringing here so and so much fur
priced at such-and-such a pelt and so
and so many slave girls priced at
such-and-such per head and I implore you
to bring me a wealthy merchant with a
lot of dinars Arab silver Arab gold
cords and a lot of Durham's Arab silver
coins who will pay me what I asked
without haggling
the story tells us about one of the
links in the great trade and exchanged
networks that brought dear M's and cilix
to Scandinavia slaves and fur to to the
Middle East and amber to China the Arab
Caliphate is one of the two great
empires of the Mediterranean this time
Mediterranean culture and religion
expanded greatly around the year
thousand Christianity making it to
northern northern Europe to Eastern
Europe Islam making it to the eastern
Russia to Central Asia even to India and
also to sub-saharan Africa all in the
long year thousand that is the period we
teach in this class the kingdom of Mali
in the Sahel south of of the of the
Sahara was not only the place that
supplied Europe and and the Arab world
with most of its gold
it was also an area that converted to
Islam in the 11th century the cultures
of the Mediterranean pushed out in all
directions most distantly to Greenland
which was saddled just before the year
thousand by a small group of
Scandinavians
it's a beautiful gorgeous place to live
wouldn't you like to move there I can
send you know these are their these are
the foundations of their houses it's
gorgeous but and there's plenty of green
grass where you can feed leave livestock
for the short summer the winter is long
and it's coming soon and those icebergs
might be pretty but they're not going to
feed you so why did they move there well
the ocean had riches fish of course but
also walruses their tusks can be
polished and carved and looked very much
like elephant ivory and sold at great
prices certainly in Europe I mean now
found out also inside now though
probably not the
a walrus tusks from from Greenland
now green that has another disadvantage
for if you want to sell if you want to
ship walrus tusks over to Europe
no trees grows there grower there is too
cold you can't build boats but the
Greenland has quickly learned that there
was wood on the other side in North
America Labrador is heavily forested
just before the years thousand they
started to go there they even built a
settlement at the northern spot of
Newfoundland enhancer meadows which has
been excavated this is a reconstruction
of wonder that their turf houses built
in just around the year thousand and so
Meadows proves that Scandinavians lived
in North America during the Middle Ages
it also gives us fascinating hints about
further excursions
there are butternuts in this settlement
butternuts don't grow in newfoundland
only south of the Gulf of st. Lawrence
so we know that the Scandinavians there
got them either by trading with American
Indians or by going even further south
to get them themselves and I wonder Mary
how far south do you think they got
well we step on to the Americas I see
all these people standing at the back
there are a few scattered seats up here
in front if you're miserable you can you
can find chairs um
I want to thank Lynn and the Graduate
School for making it possible for us to
continue on our voyage today in the long
year 1000 and just to make perfectly
clear what is the long year 1000 we
talked about the long the long 19th
century
well we've expanded this a little bit
longer given how slowly time might have
moved to think of this from 800 to 1200
but we turn to it turns it may very well
be and onder's and I are now embarking
on a little investigation of the
evidence that may or may not in the end
tell us that there were Norseman who got
all the way not only did they not like
icebergs in the winter unders but they
wanted to go to you Catan and see what
is there with this rather a strange ship
that looms up in a fragment at chichen
itza from just the long year 1000 this
long year 1000 we look at rather
differently in the americas for the
connections here and if we go back and
think about the currents and what the
oceans do for us they in fact the
currents of along the South American
coast are ice cold and make it almost
make it impenetrable in many ways to
cross the Pacific and so there's little
evidence there's periodic evidence for
some stray contacts but not the kind of
sustained trade nor the writing in most
places that allows us to see it but it
is these we have addressed ourselves
over the course of the semester and
created in creating assignments for our
students I'm happy to see some of them
are here
today the 21 graduate students from nine
departments and programs who are
enrolled in this class we have
challenged our students to think about
what is the nature of knowledge how is
it stored and communicated whether we're
in the Andes or how is it that certain
materials become the privileged ones how
is it that the textile primacy of the
Andes emerges and what do we do in a
world without Garrety without certain
kinds of domestic animals that we find
that we expect so much well we depend
heavily on archaeology and from the
Andes it has been really a time of great
riches in understanding the worry whom
we can just wrap in two hour-long year
1000 where there have been stunning
discoveries finally the kinds of
discoveries that make it possible for us
to imagine some of the loot that was by
and large sacked from these cities or we
can turn to the north coast and we can
see these great Adobe cities Changchun
probably one of the largest cities in
the new world in the year 1000 and where
some of the longest textiles of the
world have been retrieved we've assigned
our students in fact two weeks ago we
had quite a feast when we assigned to
them the challenge of preparing not only
the possibility of the feast of the Year
1000 from three parts of the world but
also the daily peasant food and as well
as what is eaten in the time of famine
and it turns out that famine and feast
are sometimes the same because of the
amount of labour that it takes to get
those termite eggs for example that
might be both will step north from the
Andes and just continue our our food
tour to the maize based diet that would
transfer
the world and as we had our students
look at the questions of what these
wonderful what the wonderful meals were
in the year 1000 how subsequently some
of these fundamental plant stuffs would
change the diet of the entire world
especially in the time of the discovery
of the Americas we looked at the way the
tools and transportation and materials
change the world or not we had robust
discussions in our class about the
problem of the absence of the wheel in
the Americas except for its use as a toy
as you see here and what that means when
you're making anything from pulley and
making a building to weather when you
are making ceramics we have we talked
about the the challenges of games what
the world games were like in the world
with before the discovery of the rubber
of the Americas and really focused in on
the absence of team sports by and large
until that moment we turned in
particular than in Mesoamerica to the
great period of toltec domination which
comes about at the north of Yucatan and
north of Mexico City in two great cities
Tula and chichen after the collapse
around the year 800 of the great Maya
cities of the south and this is kind of
a heartbreaking moment because this is
when we lose all the data this is when
writing really stops being so widespread
and so we don't have we can find
fine-grained historical data day by day
blow-by-blow accounts before the Year
800 and not easily afterwards but we do
now have the strong sense of one
particular ruler at Chichen itzá a ruler
named Kaku Kaku Pakal who for the later
9th and early 10th century was
instrumental in the major constructions
of Chichen Itza
and it's from it's in this moment 900 to
1100 when things begin to get really
really interesting and we see
Mesoamerica at its greatest wingspan as
we turn naught and find that it is the
turquoise that is coming from New Mexico
and the gold that is coming from lower
Central America all finding its way to
both Tula and to Chichen itzá Tula here
a great northern city and it is from
here then that we realize and can
understand the connections all the way
to the American Southwest we're in the
same mines that today yield principally
turquoise they were fertile places for
gold and silver in the early years of
Spanish domination of the American
Southwest and also pre-hispanic times
and around the Year 1000 not much of it
gold and silver are not of much interest
it is the powerful powerful blue-green
stone that we see here and that in fact
is what can be mined today how else do
we see these connections for surely the
turquoise in the all across Mesoamerica
is emblematic of that contact to the
American Southwest
well here's what's new in recent years
the discovery by taking the samples of
the pots that were excavated in the 19th
century and that are at the Museum of
American American Museum of Natural
History today that there's chocolate in
these pots in the American Southwest and
it's tropical chocolate that was grown
down in the Maya region and sent to the
great city of Pueblo Bonito
in Chaco Canyon that perhaps many of you
visited on your drives across the United
States
finally it takes us in the year 1000 and
is there anyone here from the state of
Illinois
have you been to Cahokia good
the sense of the Year 1000 Cahokia was a
city of 50,000 it was the largest city
north of chichén itzá in this in this
period it is perhaps where we'll end
right now as we come back in our year
1000 closing our loop as close to us as
we can come in this class so I would
like to just say that in the experience
of teaching with Marian Anders and
thinking about what makes the world of
in the year 1000 different from the
world later or earlier that one of the
differences that we noticed I think Mary
noticed was that there were no new
religions after the Year 1000 and then
people in the class would say of course
what about Mormonism
what about Sikhism but and there but
these are these the new religions the
religions that take shape after the year
1000 are remixes of older of religions
that exist and what's very striking
about the year 1000 is that even though
there's no new technology so the
different forms of transportation that
people are using they're walking they're
using wheeled carts they're using wooden
boats in some places they have sails in
some places they don't the news of the
major religions spreads throughout the
old world not the world we almost
everything we said all semester long
we'd say oh but not not the Americas the
and so in the year 1000 there are
several famous conversions onder's
mentioned one of the kazars who convert
to islam the bull gars convert to
judaism the Kiev Roose convert to
Eastern Orthodox religions apparently
struck by the beauty of Hagia Sophia in
Constantinople and that I think is one
of the things that's new about the year
1000 is this knowledge of a much larger
world and if you count the Noor we the
Scandinavians they even know about the
Americas
so that is the I guess the main thing I
have learned so far it's been very
refreshing to teach a course in in
conjunction with two such great teachers
and I have learned a lot from the course
we have discussed one of the things we
discussed early on is how do you what
assignments do you give at the end of
the semester to our students we
discussed a lot at how we when we teach
graduate courses have a tendency to give
the standard assignment of a long
research paper 2013 even more pages
something that I guess in some kind of
ideal world is supposed to mimic the
journal article but who writes three or
four journal articles in one month we
certainly are not capable of that we
thought of using this course as a way to
think of new ways not only a new ways of
teaching but also new ways of assessing
student outcomes so we designed some -
some of us at least unusual assignments
at the end of the term and during the
term I just give you two examples one of
them is what we had yesterday when each
of our 21 students had been was
presenting their curatorial talks on an
exhibit or a small part of an exhibit on
the year thousand that had organized in
the Museum of circa 1000 that we hope to
build as soon as we can get enough money
but so the students used a program where
you can lay out an exhibit and then they
have to decide what is the theme of my
corner of this museum what do I need to
say on the labels that are in the
exhibit cases how detail do they shall
they be what is useful to convey what I
want to convey with this exhibit we had
this all yesterday we managed to get 21
students there giving talks all in
less than one hour and fifty minutes
much thanks to me being a real martinet
about timekeeping before which I
apologize we also ask our students to
design an undergraduate syllabus for a
course on a theme coming out of this
course that they would like to teach if
they're becoming professors of the
college we are particularly excited
about that
since the three of us have decided to
offer a similar course as an
undergraduate course for the spring
semester of next academic year we are
thus excited to read our students
syllabi we are excited to see our
students teaching these kinds of courses
when they go out on the job market and
when they go out and get jobs something
that we also think would serve them very
well on the job market to be able to
bring this syllabi Mary I'm running the
the anchor leg here as part of this trio
when Lynne introduced me she introduced
me as a historian it's very I kind of
thinking exciting I'm historian up I
will say that I have felt like a
historian this semester but I have also
felt very much that I've had the
opportunity to make art historians of my
colleagues in the history department and
I think this is the kind of outcome that
when a few years ago I began thinking
about and then subsequently applied to
the mellon Foundation for a grant on
reimagining the humanities at Yale and
so we started our class in the museum
the Yale University Art Gallery we went
to the Metropolitan for a day and we end
with the virtual Museum of our class and
then a visit to the by Nikki when we
come back after Thanksgiving but we have
depended so closely all semester on the
intense reading of a few things we know
you can't possibly know
the Year 1000 when you walk out of this
semester but we hope that each week as
we have sent our students off to think
about particular new new challenges that
they do have that sense of the the way
that the thing can inform their thinking
this has in fact this semester given me
a lot of thought now newly back I feel a
little bit like Rip Van Winkle or brand
new appointee to the faculty after years
in the in SSS but the way that how do
our students come to knowledge now did
they start by reading a book do they
start by googling around do they look at
the pictures how do we in fact think
about where humanistic knowledge lies in
the era of what I would call a kind of
visual democracy that never existed
before in the past you used to have to
wait for that special seeing a
seeing-eye guide dog known as an art
historian to take you in to the museum
to help you find those pictures and
that's not the case anymore so how can
we make our teaching and inform our
assignments more deeply with with the
visual that is one of the things I've
learned I've also learned about the
isolation of the world of the Americas
before the Year 1000 it has been painful
to see how isolated before the Spanish
invasion of the new world how cut off it
is especially even in North even in the
United States and so I have recommitted
myself to this feeling that it is one
year 1,000 one very long year and it we
look forward to promulgating this
knowledge further in the future thank
you
one of the things this semester is we
constantly unders complaints about or
said he was the martinet yesterday we've
all had turns as the martinet and so we
are keen on timekeeping and that's why
we have lots of time for questions
where is Cahokia it's it's a great state
park
Valerie you worked at Cahokia perhaps
you would like to describe your first
paying job it's an East st. Louis so
yeah not too far from Crawford
Crawfordsville this the wait I'm
blanking on the name of the town where
all the riots have been Ferguson
Ferguson sorry Ferguson it's a and it
was my first paying job as I ivory
enacted Mississippi and Indian life and
made these stupendous sum of $100 a week
not bad
and there are incredible dig area types
of the destruction of much larger mounds
in East st. Louis in the 1860s it was
really a tragedy the destruction of this
of the vast range of the site yes Doug
how long is the long year and does it
vary between regions
it's as long as we need it to be as
every long century but we have for the
purpose of the course we have defined it
as 800 to 1200 but the closer you get
the better it's of course a lot of us
when you work with written documents
then you can date things often more
precisely than when you work with
archaeological documents that we all
three have worked with both kinds of of
documentation so the question is whether
what was the year 1000 in terms of say
the traditional notion in which this is
often viewed as a kind of nadir of a
cultural excitement I think we would all
say that well I'll certainly say from
the point of the new world
Cahokia will go on into the 13th century
Chaco Canyon is absolutely at its peak
this is the era of the Toltecs the this
incredible connections these are really
thrilling times in the new world and so
perhaps your history course was simply
lacking well it is true I often in my
undergraduate survey course on on
Western European history I present the
10th century as the ion century the
essential when you did not want to be
alive I think you didn't want really to
be alive in any century before the 20th
because it was things were terrible but
but it is true that it it is it is an
order both in both in Western Europe in
Byzantium and in Islam things are going
down but that's also that's where the
years house is about the time when you
have the Colonels
of new growth in all these areas in
Europe that's when it all starts that
when Europe takes off for gathering for
instance I was only gonna say that many
years ago Anderson I taught a course in
the history department about the
medieval transformation of China and
Europe and pretty much the whole
semester I would say to Anders and when
did X happen and he would say starting
in the year 1000 and so the Year 1000 is
more of a date in European history than
it is in the other regions up yes in the
back
no that's you Midway yes so the question
is what do we think is the benefit of
looking at history through this band of
time around the globe I mean I a lot of
world history is impossible to teach
because you're trying to do so much and
a lot of historians focus on one part of
the world usually based on whatever
languages they can read so I think by
focusing on a single time as opposed to
a single space you can get around the
globe with some some complexity so I
think it's a good alternative to the
stock narratives of X nation's history
and I also think it's in order to
understand any given nation's history
you need to know what was going on
around the world at that time and I
think that was a key motive motive
motivation for all of us I guess one of
the things that we've also found that's
really been beneficial is that it's very
clear to each of us that our own
knowledge of the Year 1000 only goes so
far and we hit this precipice and we go
right over it and explore new areas
because no matter how much we know we
don't know everything about the year
1000 we couldn't possibly and I think
it's been useful our students might
to differ but I think it's been useful
to model for our students that in fact
you don't know everything when you're
teaching you have to go find the answers
you sometimes have to just say I don't
know that and come back and find things
out and figure out how you're going to
come up with that piece of knowledge
it's been one of the features of our
assignments is there is not only what is
the answer but how would you get to that
answer
right here in front in studying the
spread of cultures the question is
whether there is a place for genetics in
our studies I mean there is we have
talked about it we haven't talked about
it very much in this course but it is
something that that not being a
geneticist myself and not understanding
the studies I have read several studies
of the genetics of European population
populations in and I hope I've been able
to draw responsible conclusions from
what I've been reading we have shared
some of that in this course but nobody
really took that theme and ran with it
so far far back on the on the left my
left yeah that's you
so the question is how did we deal with
questions of social and political
organization I'll just say that one of
the first things we read was the 19th
century foundational document on that
was written to imagine what social and
political organization would be among
Native Americans and other non-western
peoples by Lewis Henry Morgan in which
he lays out the framework that all
people should be able to be sorted into
savage barbaric and civilized mark I
feel like we should answer your question
mm-hmm I think to tell you the truth
that most of the time we got by with a
shorthand of are these upper strata
medium strata lower strata because we
were really looking at the connections
among different places and much less at
that changes the internal changes in
occurring in those places we did also
when we when we planned the course we
decided to organize the syllabus around
a different theme each week so we have
had the theme of bling we have the theme
of food we have the field of transport
we had the theme of calendars challenge
challenges that meets every civilization
on earth whether they know of each other
or not everybody has to eat and so forth
and one of the themes that we discussed
as possible one was was rulership and
kingship and such but it by then there's
only 13 weeks to the semester so so we
couldn't do it we do have the last class
is the discussion what is missing from
the syllabus and I just gave those
students are here one of the answers I
think should be there Paola
well first thing I will to say I so can
you give us a sense of what happened in
class any discussion is like and also
related to this how the assignments
correspond to the intellectual goals the
question is what happened in class and
how did the assignments map onto the
intellectual goals a lot of things
happen in class you should ask our
students we we try to vary what we were
doing in class as I said yesterday we
had 21 presentation at a maximum of four
minutes not four minutes in two seconds
four minutes earlier in earlier times we
have had each of us have given a lecture
on the year thousand in the region that
we know best which apparently in my case
includes Africa so I had to go out and
read some basic text books other other
classes we have had group presentations
the students have been pursuing themes
outside of class as groups most of the
work in the class is of course done
outside the actual class time so that it
is start for I hope you answer your
question I would say that one of our
goals was for students to gain depth in
familiar cultural areas and gain breadth
in unfamiliar ones so we have constantly
had what we would call the remix of the
students and we've even been insistent
we used place cards so that they could
not sit in the same comfortable seats so
to try to keep unsettling the comfort
zone as be given how uncomfortable we
were
Rey fair the question is did we consider
the role of slavery it's an important
it's an important facet of history that
we certainly disgusts we didn't devote
any particular theme to it it's it's
it's we the themes that we did for the
different classes tend to us to avoid
the more well slavery stuff not slavery
as such a word is an abstract word we
try to avoid that we we did we did touch
upon it several times as I even did in
in the lecture now no how are we doing
on time Lin are we doing okay okay
James the question is if I can try to
rephrase it James from one of our
students in the class did the course
develop as out of interest of ours in
the history or out of the pedagogy that
we might develop and regardless of which
how we answer that
how will it differ from the
undergraduate class valerie i feel that
you suggested this class to me so
perhaps i we were in a meeting and well
i i think of the three of us I'm the one
who's crazy enough to think you can
learn enough about the world 1000 the
world in the year 1000 to write a book
about it and so we started off I think
with the subject matter and then I think
the big change between a graduate and
undergraduate class will be
so many of the assignments were asking
you how to do things and and setting I
mean our goal was to give you a bigger
toolkit than you might have the students
in different departments might have
coming in to graduate school I think
with the undergraduates the goal isn't
going to be so much developing a
graduate student toolkit
I think the assignments may be more
tailored I don't know we haven't we
haven't gotten to the undergraduate
course yet and I would say one thing is
that every student including the two
undergraduates who are among the 21
brought real expertise in some part of
the world in the year 1000 to the table
and we won't expect that with
undergraduates and that's why we're
really going to have to rethink what we
do Jenny so Jenny Frederick's would like
to know how our students feel about all
this well they're not done yet and then
what are what was the second part of the
question what are would we recommend
these creative assignments to our
colleagues I think yes I mean it's it's
I mean it's Tyson to james question -
did we do this for pedagogy or for
subject matter we do it for both of
course and I certainly feel that I
learned a lot about subject matter and I
learned probably even more about
pedagogy the the I think I think we do
well as professor to vary assignments
just as assessment assignments just as
we do well in varying varying the
methods of instructions that we use and
for us it has been a laboratory to learn
about this because we have different
teaching starts the three of us and we
learn from each other and we hope our
students are learning from it as well
and maybe none of this is is none of the
assessments and so forth are brilliant
inventions that we came up with in the
last few months these are methods that
are used across campus
others of our colleagues and we have
looked at what other people have used
and tried to use it as well here in
front the question is what is what what
are what is our final assessment there
were two final assignments one was using
Sketchup to make a museum case of six to
ten objects or pictures from more than
one region in the world in the year 1000
and then the other time and that
assignment had many components making
the case I think I was profoundly
relieved I did not have to make a case
using Sketchup software it took a long
time to learn writing an essay about
their case writing labels for the case
writing text for the wall introducing
the case and then the undergraduate
syllabus those are the two main these
are third also that as we ask those
students to review the museum as a whole
to write a review of not only their own
exhibit case but all of the exhibit
cases as conceived of as a museum all
together
okay one more question you've had your
hand up a long time
the question is uh what happened in the
far southern latitudes especially given
all of that emphasis on Greenland so in
the year 1000 there are some connections
that you can see of the wari down below
down beyond Peru and into northern Chile
but it would be very modest in terms of
what what we would find that connects to
one of the Grand cultures that would be
focused in the central Andes so we
couldn't do everything that would be my
explanation for the Americas it's not as
though there are not people living there
but where we have the kind of durability
and works that were imbued with meaning
by their makers that gives us some
possibility of making an intelligent
discussion and comparison of those works
we did decide early on that we would
skip Australia altogether we were
already feeling as though we were at the
absolute limits of our that we were
constantly going over the precipices of
our knowledge as it was I was gonna say
one of the first assignments asked the
students to collect materials in their
own field of study and then also to
choose a field that was new to them and
develop a bibliography about that part
of the world in the year 1000 and one of
the students who is from Slovak from
Russian and East European and a student
he did Australia for his sample and I
remember saying to him well what
happened in the year 1000 and he said of
course you know that humans get to
Australia in 40,000 BC so that's the
start date but he said the there are
people here who will correct me I hope
is there something like the super large
marsupials anyway so there's some
category of animal in Australia that
dies out in the year 1000 and and New
Zealand is settled for the first time in
1350 so if it's on the to-do list
connectiveness at the reception where
we're going to have some food from
different parts of the world so I
encourage you to come join us on there
and I just want to say thank you